this Quran burner in the picture it's a
Quran burner that is living in Norway
yesterday in the age of 42 he passed
away even if you burned every Quran on
Earth
we will bring it back
cover to cover this person instead of
burning the Quran maybe had read the
Quran maybe he would have found that
guidance that would that would motivate
him to live
[Music]
you know they believed in jail like uh
this is magic magic
you know you're gonna jump up and down
to my dear brothers and sisters in Islam
listen if you want an opportunity to
support dawah to get this area this is
the project for you to do that I'm
saying to you very clearly you know
whether it's a dollar or whether it's a
million dollars this is the project that
you need to support so we can have a
template you know for dawah and a
community and we need to ask Allah to
duplicate this here ten times All Over
America
speaking to you from the dean dawa
center in Tampa Florida
not only one special guest but two here
to my right
how you doing
what about me here
so I wanted to get right into this it's
been all over the news but what was
interesting so there's two parts to it
we want to start with the one there was
a few of these Quran burners and one of
them before we get to him is the one
that was all over the news the other one
that most people don't know about is the
one who actually took his own life
so I want you guys to go ahead we'll
start off with this one this Quran
burner in the picture it's a Quran
burner that is living in Norway
yesterday in the age of 42 he passed
away this picture on the screen is from
the 26th of November
when he was trying to destroy our Tower
stand in Oslo in Norway they get
depressed and they don't want to live
anymore and in the end they take their
own lives
what do you think you see that and
what's your reaction when you see
something like that this is somebody
who's out there you know the guidance is
sent for him also it's supposed to be a
mercy for him for his life and now this
person is talking about how he came to
his daoist then that's what you also you
have you give Dao you invite people you
educate people to the purpose of life
why they've been created why they're
here this guy's trying to you know
instead of taking the book reading it
see what Solutions can come for his life
and then he ends up taking his own life
subhanallah Allah has told us that the
peace that people seek that which I mean
it will bring peace to their heart is
only found in the liquor of Allah in the
remembrance of Allah and the Quran the
Quran is that remembrance of Allah
so if this person instead of burning the
Quran maybe had read the Quran maybe he
would have found that guidance that
would that would motivate him to live
that would show him that there is a
higher purpose to life
but instead if you burn the Quran and he
rejected the Quran you see what it did
to his life it brought him no peace it
brought him no purpose it brought him no
Solitude Instead at the age of 42 I mean
young comparatively he took his own life
so the lesson here and I think it's very
important is people should learn the
Quran whether they want to accept Islam
or not is up to them we don't force it
on anybody our taoistan's been attacked
multiple times and you can see I mean
the first time that was attacked by a
man who was wielding a metal baton and
things
there are others who came to our stall
to argue to debate but they ended up
accepting a Quran
and many of them today are Muslim you
can see the videos online
there is a brother named Richard as we
can find his videos three times he came
and you can see debates and argue and
alhamdulillah he was open-minded enough
that he took the Quran he read it he
came back he questioned us again
and he came back a third time he
accepted Islam and now you see the
videos of him giving dawah of him it
reconnected him to his family it's very
interesting story there's brother
Richard's from Mexico and subhanallah
later on I found out I'd actually run
into him around my younger days but I
didn't know at the time
uh he came to our Stan and the first
time he came in it's on it's on the one
message Foundation Channel he he had
questions some little bit of uh
hostility and things and we had a good
conversation and then he came back and
then he had a second conversation and
then he came back and alhamdulillah on
this third time he ended up accepting
Islam the shahadas online it's in the
video
his Pastor who was his church preacher
looked around saw that he was missing
and said where is he because his whole
family went to that church and uh
his people told him he went to Balboa
Park he spoke to somebody ended up
becoming Muslim so his Pastor decided
that he's going to come and debate with
me and he comes and the videos online uh
Patrick guitarist I believe they was
you'll find the video in the one message
Foundation Channel and he comes in
debates
and this pastor now he's not open even
when you show him the clear
contradictions and mistakes you join the
miracle the Quran is not open
but the benefit that came out of that is
when that video was posted his own
Richard's own family who was very well
ingrained into this church saw that
their Pastor fell apart and they stopped
going to his congregation and
alhamdulillah Richard's mother ended up
accepting Islam right before her death
and right before her that subhanallah
she accepted Islam she told him go Miho
and he go to the dawah and he went and
he got the call when he was there that
his mother passed away
and we have the video you know he's
crying and this Brother Richard
mashallah you can see him now with this
beautiful
beards in the Masjid when we went to
Mexico his father has a very large
property in Mexico he went out there he
reconnected with his father like it
brought the family together and he
started to give his father dawah and he
helped when we went out there we went
and gave dawa you see it brought his
life to purpose he found what was the
what was missing in his life
so people have a choice Allah gave us a
choice the Quran is a guidance
it is the guidance for who for the
people of taco
so if you have that love for Allah if
you have that awareness that there is a
Creator you want the guidance the Quran
will guide you
and if you reject that guidance then the
Quran is a proof against you that's why
the prophet salallahu said the Quran is
it's either for you or upon you now this
person he had the Quran in his hand but
instead of benefiting from it he burnt
it you see the the despair that he had
in this life and imagine his Hereafter
so can we say it's out of the love now
we want to prevent people from and
ending up in the same situation so now
we want to motivate people to actually
read the book
you know that was always been out of
love
we don't benefit financially from people
becoming Muslim you know we have a
brother Farooq in San Diego it's one of
very close brothers
and he became Muslim with us and he back
in the 90s uh maybe 95 96
um and one of the first things when he
was accepting Islam is he said all right
well how much does it cost
what I gotta say you know and that's the
thing because churches are like that you
know you become a member of a church you
have to financially contribute to the
church like the Mormon Church
23 sometimes wow yeah that's like worse
than Uncle Sam but at least 10 percent
they take from your gross income right
and then I mean then you have other
taxes and dues and so that you pay to
them as well but imagine I mean ten
percent of your wealth gone not to the
poor not to the needy not to focus no to
the church to the church Elders to the
prophet that they elect now it's
interesting they have elections to who's
going to be a prophet now all right so
so what does that mean it's it it
financially makes sense for them to get
people right if you look at Jehovah
Witnesses if you look at the Catholic
church I mean that's one of the biggest
money-making schemes in history they 100
more money than the market that's why
they are willing to compromise the
message true to lose their congregation
yeah
I mean if you look at the Vatican
um one of the guys I know his name was
Martin Isa he was a Chaldean era
Christian from Iraq and I used to work
with him and he told me I worked in the
Vatican you know when he first came from
Iraq because he spoke Arabic he spoke
Aramaic he spoke French he spoke a lot
of like English but it was very good
languages as a refugee they had him work
at the Vatican this is something he told
me himself he said you know I used to
work at the Vatican and I used to take
people from Eastern Europe for tours and
we would have this underneath you know
we go there are floors underneath would
have this preserved body of a man and we
would have nitrous oxide tanks that we
would switch out to keep the body frozen
we would tell these poor refugees that
this person it's a miracle
he's just by himself he said I knew we
were lying
say you know these fit and then he told
me he goes look when I saw that I lost
my faith in Christianity even though he
was Iraqi Christian he wasn't Muslim
it's not like a fairy tale he became
Muslim no I'm telling you he told me he
said look the treasures the paintings
the gold the the wealth that is hidden
in the Vatican you wouldn't believe me
if I told you and this is a Christian
and he but he had left Christianity when
I met him but he wasn't Muslim he never
became Muslim but
this is the thing to them it's money
making for us it's not alhamdulillah if
you become Muslim you don't have to
donate to anything I mean you know as a
Muslim if you have wealth you pay zakat
which is you give money from saved money
to the poor not to the Imam not to the
Masjid not to die alhamdulillah in San
Diego for example we have no paid the
art if people become Muslim it doesn't
matter to us financially
we have just this love for people to
know their creator to no purpose in life
to be saved from the despair of
hopelessly going through life without
purpose without morals without guidance
and ending up in the Hellfire we don't
want that for anybody we don't want that
for our worst enemies the prophet Allah
peace and blessings be upon him he would
go to the worst enemies at the time who
were torturing him who were attacking
him and he would pray for their guidance
and you would be kind to them and you
would give them gifts and you would try
to bring them towards Islam not because
it financially benefited him just
because he wanted good for them and
that's what you want for people
absolutely what was your uh reaction
when you saw this person now taking his
own life he went from burning the Quran
to you think he'd have some
peace in his life but obviously he
didn't he was void of it and he ends up
taking it you know when uh
the pharaoh
wanted to challenge Musa
he invited the people he made a public
scene
to show the people
that
I defeated Musa
this is the Pharaoh now yeah the Pharaoh
yeah that's a long time ago
so what happened at the end he was
disgraced
this person did the same thing
he just you know I'm burning the Quran
imagine I I wanted I wanted I wanted to
think about this
someone who never heard about the Quran
before
what is he going to say what is that
what these guys doing this is this is
news okay it's he burned Quran okay what
is Quran it's a Muslim thing that I'm
just you know sorry he got the attention
he he got
you know he what do you think he's
working now yeah bring more people to go
what was the intention of the of the
Pharaoh is to put down Allah
what is Allah saying what Musa came with
Allah equipped him with the serpent the
snake and the staff he wanted to show
them I'm going to bring this sorcerer to
defeat you I'm going to defeat your
Quran I'm going to humiliate your Quran
but in fact what the Pharaoh did he made
the sign apparent to the people the
people saw it
to the extent that the sorcerers
themselves who came to his Aid they
became Muslims
and we have seen people who were I think
there was some guy who became a Muslim
right the the the Swedish some
Congressman I mean was a hater you know
something yeah yeah so you know you know
these guys are really they actually
opened up yeah and they read it yeah
they got to a point like hold on let me
uh can you imagine how many people did
not know about the Quran because of this
act they will know about the Quran
I don't know how much because you guys
also do some counseling as imams yes so
how much uh with psychology would you
think is this a projection of what's
inside what a person's struggling with
and the terminal and pain and now they
look and now they project that pain all
the Muslims now the Muslims and now it's
like this deep hate that they have
within they start pushing in the wrong
direction
how much of that would you say it is I
think that's that's the majority of the
islamophobia that we see today is
because they have some issue they're
dealing with in their life and they're
projecting it on to Muslims but
projected pain yes of course I mean for
example many people uh and not just with
Muslims this happens with racism and
Prejudice across the board you look at
somebody who loses their job they want
to blame Mexicans for it somebody who uh
you know whatever maybe they didn't get
into a university that they wanted to
get into be whatever then they're going
to blame affirmative action for it
everybody wants to throw the blame on
somebody got it and the same thing like
I was in Europe recently and I mean I I
work with medical devices so I see a lot
of factors I went to a factory and the
workers were almost 80 Muslim from
Northern Africa the workers all being
done by Muslims and you know I was
looking around I was seeing all these
brothers and you know working and it was
interesting and I went outside and then
I'm not going to mention the name of the
country but there was a man who was
homeless from the people of that country
we're sitting there homeless and you
know he saw me and and of course I had a
beard and things and he he kind of
murmured a little bit like he was not
something clear where you could see he
had some hatred in his eye and you know
I didn't speak the language you speak of
but I wanted to speak to him like look I
mean it's not like Muslims are taking
your job you're not working and we're
out here doing your work for you you
know we're running your country you want
to kick these people out who's going to
do your work you know so this is the
thing people project their insecurities
their pain over instead if they would
just take that message and take it into
their heart they would learn that Islam
would solve that pain
you know to the Sheikh's Point even if
you look at the height about the boy and
the king of prison it's the same thing
the same thing yeah they gathered all
the people if they told them you want to
kill me you know take an arrow say in
the name of the rub of this this child
and in the end everybody started
becoming Muslim
so every time people use propaganda
against Islam it will only backfire on
them let me show you guys we're going to
jump into can I just say something
quickly before you go there you know
what is what is the ruling on burning
the Quran to begin with
actually many Muslims may not know that
that actually any old versions of the
Quran the recommendation that you burn
it
no no
versions he means like if you have an
old musaf like an old written Quran in
your house and let's say it gets worn
out paper gets worn out you're unable to
read it now how do you properly dispose
of it respectfully not out of disgrace
or or anger if you burn it it's not
heresies it is not right it is like
flipping out I mean they can look in
books across
humbly across this is the respectful way
yeah but respectfully like respect but
we understand that his intention is not
respectful right you don't want to bury
it or put it in somewhere that's going
to get disgraced
but let's assume that they burned all
the copies of the Quran on the face of
this Earth
it's isn't that he he won the Quran
let's assume now that let's assume that
Quran burn day and every virgin every
copy on the face of this Earth no the
translation everything no there's only
one that's it just translation okay
whatever five children Yeah we actually
need two because you know
five children just get five children sit
together they will produce another Quran
in less than a day
five how about four
even if you have one the thing is that's
a beautiful the Quran yeah and we hope
that people watching especially those
that are not Muslim will go and get a
Quran and if they don't have one they
can come reach out to the one message
Foundation we'll send them a free one
and they'll read it the Quran is
preserved not just in the book format
but in the hearts of the Muslims what
some people hearing this for the first
time I mean we take this for granted a
lot of times you know but people hearing
this for the first time this is like wow
so so look at this right
if we look at the Bible today and and
people watching this is a challenge for
anybody watching bring the pope bring
any Minister any preacher any Christian
Evangelical bring a Bible scholar and
put him in front of me and see any one
of them that can recite the Bible verse
by verse letter by letter one in the
whole two billion strong Christianity
this is the is what's the pope's name
Francis Pope Francis is that that's the
latest one or did he passed the Benedict
okay is this probe if you brought him
here look he's a representative
supposedly of God on Earth directly in
touch he hasn't memorized he has not
memorized the Bible are you sure I'm
pretty sure he might give some people
calling you challenge let's do it all
right I'll fly I'll fly to the Vatican
myself yeah with my own ticket I'll pay
for it myself and I'll sit in front of
this is well known I mean this is not
I'm just speechless you know this is
something that you cannot we've been out
there it's impossible giving dawa since
the mid 90s and we've put this challenge
out we've had every Christian
Evangelical islamophob fly from the UK
and across the U.S to come to San Diego
and challenge us till today they have
not been able to produce one single
person that is memorized about but
this year it's from Egypt already asked
him in Egypt how many people they
memorize the Quran through a rock you
hit three of them you come to you come
can I say can I tell you an issue that
is very interesting
most of the people who memorize the
Quran yes
you come to Pakistan they don't speak
Arabic because if you even try to
memorize the Bible like what version you
don't have to go to the Greek right and
they memorize it in Arabic yeah I mean
if you come to Pakistan for example or
India or many of these countries the
people aren't Arab they don't know
Arabic and they memorize the Quran
letter by letter Sound by sound let me
tell you one more thing which is very
important especially for some of our
doctors that's kind of misunderstand
things sometimes
in North Africa
[Music]
many of them memorized by writing it out
and I met a brother who was shankriti
from the shanaka as a tribe in North
Africa and he said you know in my
Village when we finished memorizing we
would write out the entire Quran from
memory twice without a mistake before we
got the sun now imagine that that means
that if you were given a blank piece of
paper doctor
and a pen to write
from memory you would be able to write
each one of those that are from that
Northern African area they would be able
to write out the entire Quran without a
mistake
now imagine that how can you burn the
Quran it's in the hearts it's in the
mind it's in Pride even right now
Ramadan is coming up and I invite our
non-muslim neighbors and co-workers to
come to the mosques our Masjid is open
come and you will hear the entire Quran
recited from memory in this month
every Masjid across not every but almost
every Masjid you will have akari half as
somebody has memorized the Quran and
they will lead the people in prayer from
memory they will recite the whole Quran
from beginning to end in this month one
just every night about right so now
imagine across the Muslim World
Indonesia Malaysia any from South Africa
to Russia to England to America across
the Muslim world you can't get rid of
the Quran
and and again this is a a warning for
those that think that these kind of
things will stop Islam we have an Islam
of hope that comes to San Diego and what
they did is they took a picture of me
actually a pretty good picture I
appreciate that and they made a big
poster and they told me are you a
scholar are you a prophet I told them no
and the way of the Muslim Scholars is
that even if somebody was and I'm not
but if somebody was they wouldn't call
themselves a scholar when called an
island
he gives this concept not as a Hadith
that whoever says he's ignorant right
Muslim Scholars will never go around
bragging about these things right so he
asked me are you a scholar I said no is
that you have it no so they thought they
got me on something so they made a big
poster a life-size huge poster a picture
of me and it says jehosh man said he's
not a scholar right as if they got me on
something right so it's okay one brother
and this video is on our Channel and one
message founder one Mexican brother he
saw that poster he kept walking then he
saw me and he said who are you I saw a
poster of you are you somebody famous or
something and I was like no no I'm just
a regular guy but let me tell you about
Islam subhanallah he took shahada he
accepted Islam the video is online it's
not like something we can we're just
here say you know so what does that mean
dear plan to try to disgrace us to stop
Islam ended up being attacked one for us
if that poster wasn't there the guy
would have just walked by yeah
so every trick they do is only going to
backfire on them but let me get uh here
in the essence of time I want to get you
guys reactions so we covered one of the
people who are burning the guidance that
was sent for them also the Quran
verbatim word of God Almighty Allah and
he ends up taking his life this is
another one of the main characters there
he's a politician and this is what I
want you guys to check out and give us
your reactions there's some of the chats
between Swedish Danish politician Rasmus
polidan and young boys on the internet
the convicted racist politician who is
notorious for his so-called Crown
burning Taurus and anti-islam hate
spends extensive time on social media
platform Discord chatting with young
boys about sexually explicit topics
[Music]
although paludon has been charged with
14 offenses in the past including racism
defamation and traffic laws his online
chats did not elicit any action under
Danish law so uh you see this now his
life's coming out what are your what's
your reaction to this shame
well I I think this this is clear that
because usually there'll be attacks you
know on the prophet saws they'll throw
different Slanders and whatnot and then
it seems like their life gets uncovered
and you see a lot of these things again
another person who is down a dark hole
in reality and Hill they need help I
like that point they need they need they
need help they need guidance and you
know they need the Quran they need the
Quran the problem with those people you
know this campaign of burning the Quran
is
during the time of the Prophet too but
it wasn't burning them I like what you
just started coach I I didn't like you
didn't like man this guy should burn in
hell this guy did it he said he needs
help I mean he didn't say obviously this
is a book you know this is a book what
the what what problem do you have with a
book I mean if if you have you know this
is intellectual just read it and then it
is pretty cool man because a lot of
times people are thinking man these guys
are extremely radical you're talking
about love you're talking about I'll
give you yeah
you know if if they really want to do it
in a respectful way we will have a
campaign and go to San Diego and invite
all the Muslims who have old virgins old
copies of the Quran and we're gonna burn
it with them the old copies and they can
come and you know but in a respectful
way and we're going to explain the
people this is the ruling how we get rid
of old versions of the Quran I mean this
doesn't bother us we really feel sorry
for them you know it's sad you know one
of the things is
we as Muslims and and I hope especially
for the non-muslim audience watching
they'll take a point to this we want to
show respect
when we talk about Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him we don't even say
his name except that we say with him
that peace and blessings be upon him
when we talk about Mary we say peace and
blessings be upon her we talk about
Moses we say peace and blessings be upon
him we talk about Abraham we say peace
and blessings be upon him we don't
disrespect any of the prophets we speak
well about them you will never see a
Muslim making a cartoon of them you will
never see a Muslim disrespecting their
image or even making their image we
shouldn't even make images how that's
how of high esteem we hold them in you
never see a Muslim burning even the
corrupted forms of the Bible you never
see us instigating this kind of hate we
as Muslims want good we want
conversations we want dialogue as the
Sheikh said people like him who like the
first one that we mentioned who took his
own life the second one that's out there
on the internet talking to little
children in inappropriate ways we want
good for them we want them to have
guidance we want them to have that peace
that will bring them to Salvation in
this life and the Hereafter and that's
why we do dawah is to bring that message
to them so they can have that we give
out English translation the Quran on the
street free right we why we we spend our
own money we could take that money and
spend on ourselves instead we take that
money people that donate to the one
message Foundation what do we do with
that money we don't get paid we take
that money we put it toward promotion
towards videos towards uh you know
buying containers of English language
translation and giving them out free of
charge why we want to share something
that has benefited us that has brought
peace in our life and will help them so
in the end we realize these people need
help and we are here to help them we're
not here I really want to address the
people who may get influence
by these individuals
during the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam they had the
same campaign
but different again nothing new right no
it is prophesies in the Quran where
Allah is
Allah said that those who disbelieve
would advise those who are coming to
Makkah to perform Umbra or Hajj because
this is a ritual from the time of
Ibrahim
that don't listen to the Quran and when
it's recited make noise so it doesn't
get to you and they went actually to the
extreme that they had a cartoon campaign
cotton campaign that at the entries of
Mecca anybody who's coming out of town
would that cotton so you'll hear the
Quran Allah look at this now there was
one smart man
when he asked them why what the Quran
would do to me he said this is the Jinn
you know they believed in Jinn like uh
this is magic magic
you know you're gonna jump up and down
so you know he put the cotton in his you
know Ear hearing their advice his name
is
it's authentic this is authentic so when
he went around the Kaaba he saw the
prophet sallallahu
look at this now I said I'm a smart man
you know I'm not going to act upon the
advice of these guys let me hear what
this guy has to say
I I he actually he was someone who
accused people from Jinn possession
himself and he he would because Jinn is
a culture that was there in in the
Arabia at the time
so he he said okay let me hear to him
let me hear what he has to say so he
approached the prophet sallallahu they
are telling me about you that what is
this you know and he said what is he
said in alhamdulillah
an introduction the introduction that we
do yes stop
this is I'm a Muslim he became a Muslim
that was it yeah
so we learn a lot from this one because
most people are the Masters they're just
like like sheep just follow this man was
like hold on I'm gonna go ahead and
check it for myself now if most people
did this they might have you know the
same thing happen to them or at least
they would not you know be fooled by all
the you know nonsenses out there I'll
tell you something interesting
um you know who is the number one
narrator of Hadith who narrated the most
Hadith
his real name is
this man his tribe that came and he had
you know when he came the quraish told
him so it's very interesting he was a
leader from his people and the people
that are not Muslim you should listen to
this
they he was a leader of his people when
he used to come to Makkah before the
people would greet him you know but this
time they came outside of Makkah to
greet him so he was like something's
different
so they told him that as a man and he's
a magician and he's this and don't
listen to him just like the smear
campaigns that they have against Muslim
Dua today you know he's this
fundamentalist wahhabi whatever they
want to call him today
and they they told him put cotton in
your ears and one of the cotton fell out
and he was putting it back and he
thought you know what I'm a leader of my
people they come to me for advice how
could I be that feeble-minded that I
can't differentiate between right and
wrong yeah yeah I mean people out there
just read the Quran use you I've read
the Bible Insider now back forward have
you seen my copy of the Bible it's all
marked up right and I've read the Quran
and I realized the Quran to be the truth
and if you don't believe that just read
the Quran that's all we're asking read
it or put on in years yeah it's not
going to help
as the Sheikh mentioned when he heard
the prophet salaam begin and he heard it
and he accepted Islam and he went back
to his people and he gave them that one
and none of them accepted in the
beginning except one young man
and this young man he came with the film
in amaradosi to the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him and the Phil said
you know my people they're not listening
oh prophet of Allah make data they're
destroyed
and the person raised his hands and this
young man he said I was afraid that if
the prophet makes a Dua a supplication
for the destruction of my people like
the people of lot or Noah they would be
destroyed but the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he had that love for mankind
for their guidance so instead of making
Dua for their destruction the
supplication for their destructions he
supplicated oh Allah guide the people of
God beautiful peace look how beautiful
that is
they weren't listening he didn't say go
and do a Spanish Inquisition and wipe
them out or genocide them or or like we
see in the Bible the amalek you know go
in and Massacre all the no he said Allah
guide them
he wanted good for them just like we
want good for people just like we want
we're following them do you know the
mercy who that young man was that was
imagine the top narrator
all that reward 5 000 plus authentic
yeah wow this is amazing go ahead and
finish your point so all that reward
will go to to Philip namra dosi because
he was intelligent enough to listen to
the message
so that's what we asked the people
listen to what Islam has to say don't
let CNN or fox or islamophobes tell you
what Islam is about let us tell you
we're Muslim
listen to what we're saying we believe
in the one God the one created that the
Creator who sent Abraham and Moses and
Jesus and Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon all of them we love all of them
we show why there is a United message
one message that all the prophets
brought it's because there was the same
message that was brought from the same
creator people changed it up some people
started worshiping their prophets some
people started corrupting their religion
changing their religion changing the
rules but we have the preserved message
in that Quran that instead of burning
you should be reading and it is divinely
preserved so even if some guy comes out
and says there is a hole in the
narrative you see whatever Allah
commands whether it is or whether it is
khadari I really would like the the
viewers understand the difference
between the two like Allah commanding us
to be Muslims this is meaning that we
have a choice
you understand because if Allah will we
would all be Muslims so Allah let us
choose to be Muslims or not to be
Muslims but when it came to to the
preservation of the Quran it's
you know like they say in the biblical
tradition it's written it shall be done
this is this is uh truly so you don't
have to have a scenario how they
preserved it and how they did it
actually if you doubt one letter from
the Quran then you have an issue with
your belief system so anybody who's
sincere who really wants to know they
ask the creator of Heaven on Earth for
guidance to shall be made clear
brothers and sisters this is your
brother Hassan chibli and I'm so excited
so grateful to Allah to be standing
right here at the dean center that is
being established in Tampa by brother
Eddie from the dincha we are so excited
that he shows in Tampa to be this Hub
and Center for dawa not just locally
alhamdulillah where we can host seminars
programs dawa activities there's enough
space for a school gymnasium Masala and
a studio that can inshallah reach people
globally to share the beauty of Islam
we're so excited to have this
established here locally in Tampa and I
want to encourage you all do what you
can to help complete this project and
make it a reality and I invite you all
to join me in supporting the center of
may Allah for all of us to share the
beauty of the Deen with all Humanity I
mean
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you